ils vivent parfois au bord des routes
nationales pas forcément loin de paris
mais toujours loin de ceux qui les
dirigent leur vie ressemble assez peu à
ce qu'on voit à la télé ils ont le
sentiment d'être des français de seconde
zone comme s'ils étaient invisibles ces
français ne veulent plus se taire ils
ont des choses à dire la france oubliée
c'est une rencontre avec ces citoyens
qui ne se résignent pas à la fatalité la
france oubliée c'est montrer ce qu'on ne
voit jamais
aujourd'hui je me rends en isère dans la
commune de pont de claix
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour alors ça c'est laurence
et sa wii et jean-pierre jp pour tout le
monde alors on est où là les amis on
apprend une clé on est chez jp c'est son
appartement dans la tour la voilà on est
à quoi 15 kilomètres de grenoble
alors moi actuellement je suis taxi vélo
je fais partie de l'association
solidarité sdf grenoble et
rien et logeant de la rue aux plus
démunis ont fait une mare une
distribution tous les mercredis soirs là
on va la faire la maison du tourisme
on va monter on va prendre un petit café
là parce que ça pique et puis vous allez
nous expliquer tout ça et tu vas
expliquer un peu ton parcours laurent
pas soucié qui est un peu atypique
on fait comme ça hein c'est par les
choses fausses couettes univ repas avec
ce masque parce que non j'ai pas le
droit mais c'est vous c'est moi qui lui
ai offert et c'est surtout que ça fait
pas pour nous les clients ça fait pas un
professionnel il se met en confiance les
comprends un peu vous pouvez interdit
aux cons voilà du coup je sais pas si on
peut rentrer si vous avez loin vous
n'êtes pas sûr de ressortir au mas ctt
s'est fait fait va te coucher
allez pas de couches et de sebah cuisine
où on va vous faire le café où as tu
peux
donc toi laurent tu as un parcours un
peu atypique du parti de départ de chez
tes parents très tôt
oui j'avais qu'à l'âge 16 ans tu vivais
dans le nord c'est ça oui je suis parti
parce que voilà c'est quoi voilà
on va dire que j'ai fait de la merde du
coup je suis parti de chez mes parents
et j'ai voyagé a dénombré un peu de
poids dans la délinquance à des trains
n'ont même pas thatta rien foutu à
l'école oui ça et j'étais très bagarreur
normalement je devais avoir un diplôme
d'horticulteurs paysagiste et je les ai
pas eus parce que j'ai mis un coup de
tête à mon directeur à le jour de la
remise des diplômes
il m'a appelée une fois l'handicaper je
suis monté j'ai pris mon diplôme j'ai eu
un coup de tête j'ai cassé son nez il y
avait l'académie je sais pas quoi ils
vont supprimer mon don du ciel du jeu
nul et mon diplôme en dix ans n'accepte
pas la violence du coup j'ai pas de
diplôme presse que toi tu souffre d'un
handicap
oui qui s'appelle la maladie de trentels
lorrain c'est générer dans tout ce qui
est au niveau de la spasticité des gens
l'information elle part du cerveau pour
que je déroule ma jambe entièrement
sauf que l'information passe pas
entièrement c'est comme si on prend une
gaine électrique on retire de petits
morceaux de gaines le courant il passera
pas comme il faut pas c'est pareil tu
pas encore en fauteuil roulant malade il
l ait dégénéré sans que ça veut dire
elle peut que augmenté elle redescendra
pas c'est un peu comme le diabète
tu peut pas soigner le diabète tue lui
donne à manger pour qu'il te laisse
tranquille cette eau et ben moi c'est
pareil ça peut arriver dans mes bras
j'espère pas ce que j'en donne
tremblements comme ouais j'ai quelques
tremblements et je ne mets pas de
blocage c'est de ma vie normale et 6,6 à
fait que ma maladie elle s'aggrave pas
tant pis façon il faudra quand même que
je passe par là tu arrives à vivre
normalement
ouais à travailler ouais avec plus de
difficultés parce que j'ai la médecine
du travail qui m'ont mis beaucoup de
aulas en me disant j'ai pas le droit de
porter j'ai pas le droit de marcher trop
longtemps j'ai pas le droit de rester
assis trop longtemps j'ai pas le droit
de monter les escaliers mais j'y arrive
très bien pour eux je suis handicapé
donc je peux rien faire normalement je
suis censé être inapte au travail mais
ils m'ont dit vu que tu es jeune tu vas
pas te mettre en
petite chute totale doit évidemment tout
ce que tu veux c'est travailler
ouais c'est pas rester chez toi rien
faire et voilà c'est pas une bonne idée
à part si vous voulez que je devienne
fou je me trouve plus courageux que
certaines moby certaines personnes
valides qui ferait leur journée je vais
des fermes et la snes impôts
malheureusement le laisser tout seul
c'est la chênaie à jp elle a 9 ans je
crois qu'ils gp oui elle a quel âge tu
as mais mr nô bientôt avoir dit voilà
elle a des poils c'est joyeux noël et
bonne année
alors tu t'es retrouvé sdf
oui pendant pendant combien de temps à
peu près pendant cinq six ans 5 6 ans
ouais de 16 à 22 ans
donc tu dormais dans les foyers non
temple d'or
ouais on a toujours proposé de l'aide
mais j'ai toujours refusé de l'aide en
me disant je peux me débrouiller par moi
même je suis pas et j'ai pas besoin d en
fait si on a toujours besoin d'être ne
serait-ce que quand tu es dans la rue et
que tu demande aux gens s'ils peuvent
t'aider pour manger ou quoi c'est déjà
leur demander de l'aide
donc on a toujours besoin de ça veut
faire gros cliché mais beaucoup de
riches qui passe à côté toi et regarde
en mode mais va travailler que tu fais
la barbe et ces gens qui mais je suis
pas une cuillère en argent dans la
bouche main pour ruth et de poussière
dans la rue tue son fond de teint sera
un pot de fleurs ça reviendra ou même
plus t'es dans la merde plus tu as envie
d'aider les gens c'est souvent ceux qui
sont passés par là qu'ils se disent ah
tiens il faudrait peut-être que je
l'aide parce qu'ils savent comment c est
la rencontre avec jp alors ça s'est
passé comment en fait à l'époque je
faisais une distribution tous les
mercredis 20 ans
au centre-ville de grenoble et puis un
jour à débarquer le lascar le lot et bah
tout de suite j'ai senti quelque chose
en lui était différente des autres
il avait un petit plus très rapidement
il m'a proposé de l'aide pour la
distribution qui détient sympa et en
fait voilà il sait bien m'aider
régulièrement si j'avais besoin d'aller
chercher vous proposer d'aller le
récupérer me donner la main est en fait
très rapidement on est devenus les
meilleurs amis du monde
c'est beau ce qui fait lui il sort de la
rue et ce qu'on lui a donnés à l'époque
ce qu'on a pu lui apporter des gens
anonymes des associations tout organise
maintenant qu'il est sorti de la rue il
a un appartement il veut faire un retour
quoi dire vous m'avez donné c'est à mon
tour de vous aider tu perçois une aide
de travailleurs handicapés
alors j'ai pas la reconnaissance adultes
handicapés qui fait que je peux pas voir
les aides de ne serait-ce que pour avoir
un logement adapté n'aviez pas le droit
parce que pour eux je suis pas assez
handicapée il faut être reconnus à 80%
minimum et je suis à 78,70 l'important
donc tu rentre dans aucune case
finalement c'est ça je suis dans un
cercle sans fin en fait et tu es en
couple qui vient d'avoir un suis en
couple depuis 5 ans et j'ai une petite
fille de 4 ans et ça se passe bien c'est
c'est un peu ma raison de vivre
si j'ai pas eu va pas bien il faut pas
donc là vous allez préparer les affaires
pour la marotte alors là on va prendre
des affaires pour les ramener au garage
pour que la prochaine marode mercredi on
est plus facile à les prendre et
s'évitent de monter et redescendre des
soldats on va faire ça avec vous on va
les voir je marche je vais remettre un
peu moche quand même
tout ça c'est pour la marronne ça c'est
pour les repas c'est pour stocker leurs
passes assez des vêtements
c'est assez pour les cadeaux de noël
ça c'est des donations saas pour les
maraudes sas pour rester propre
comme ça on ne dit pas à vous êtes salle
non non on est propre on sait les choses
bien ou en effet pas tu apprends ça oui
on prend la poubelle ouais prendre un
nouvel epr les délais jugés
et puis ce jeu
c'est ma hantise
ouais je veux pas finir là dedans
aïe
tu vas tomber encore séché que tu peux
faire avec moi bon vous avez pas peur
parce que là quand même
nada il ya un petit peu de vêtements
il ya une moutons milieu c'est ce qu'on
va faire on finit toujours l'émission
par une photo ouais donc plus on va la
faire ensemble cette photo il a dit ok
allez on y va parce que c'est quand même
un combat mais c'est le mot à les
ronflements un petit coup de boxe super
[Musique]